breaking news Halliburton to buy Baker
Hughes there you go the this is going to
be a combined stock and cash transaction
valued at thirty four point six billion
dollars that's a big number are you
surprised we're seeing this kind of deal
flow right now I'm surprised this
happened this [ __ ] why well just that
the price of oil you know we're at what
seventy-five today I didn't look at but
these are two very big companies and
Baker has been around for a long time
the fact that they are apparently
agreeing to this deal this quickly I
think was surprising but it does allow
them to take on Schlumberger more
effectively but I think from here on if
we do see rigs laid down and the oil
price continues to soften the fracturing
markets going to something is testimony
to their concerns about the I'll leave
that to you Doug I can't say if it's
test you know how they're you know
looking at the the long-term prospects
but I'm surprised that it happened as
quickly as it did well what are your
concerns about the long-term secular
price of oil yeah I think it's going
lower but god bless them we'll see what
happens I'll be surprised if OPEC comes
out with some significant cut myself
watching this where to you short I'm
uninvolved I'm more interested in
becoming a buyer a long-term and
investment buyer not a traitor in the
oil stocks why because we're so cheap
because the prices have gone so low yeah
I think that you you know if you have a
longer term it's a function of your
timeframe if you're three to five years
they're starting to create that so does
that in the supermajors are the the
upstream stocks what do you like I would
stick with the companies with the strong
balance sheets Exxon Devon Chevron
uh-huh in the event that the decline is
much steeper there are ones who were
gonna weather this the best